It's been a
long five years.
We've tried to resist
fear and mistrust.
Rule the Galaxy.
Cal, look into the fire.
It will warm you,
keep you company.
But left unchecked,
it will consume everything.
Until there is only.
How could you let the galaxy fall to this
unworthy machine of an empire?
Hope may feel beyond her grasp.
And I think we finally found somewhere
the empire can't reach us.
Imagine
no more looking over your shoulder.
A place that's worth fighting for.
No matter the cost.
Welcome back everyone
it's Charlie.
This is the way this will be my Star Wars
Jedi Survivor trailer video.
There's a whole bunch of Easter eggs
and references.
I know people want to see Karl casters
come to the Mandalorian and live action.
I'm in the middle of doing The Mandalorian
Season three episodes right now.
My Episode
four video was posted a couple of days,
so be sure to subscribe to get everything.
Also, give some copies of the game away
when it actually comes out in April.
Funny coincidence too,
because this week, The Mandalorian Season
three Episode four is titled The Child.
It's all about Grow Goose or plug in
to see some more order 66 flashbacks,
and they're releasing the New Jedi
Survivor trailer, which is all about
surviving Order 66
and surviving the Empire
a little bit later in the timeline
during this game,
where ten years after Revenge of the Sith,
which puts us right around
the start of the Obi-Wan Kenobi series,
just in a different part of the galaxy.
So while Darth Vader in the Inquisitors
are busy chasing down Obi-Wan
Kenobi, Caucusus is busy
dealing with this other Jedi survivor,
the guy who survived from the High
Republic era who's hundreds of years old.
It sounds like he is pissed
about what happened with Order 66.
Like, how dare you?
How dare you let the Emperor in the Empire
do this?
It sounds like he's on an antique
and Skywalker Darth Vader band.
Like he's going to bring his, quote
unquote, order to the Galaxy
just in a completely different direction
that Darth Vader wanted to take things.
But the idea is that during
the game, carcasses
is meant to be about 23 years old.
So for those of you that are wondering
how old he is compared to the characters
on The Mandalorian right now,
he'd be just a little bit younger, around
the same age as Ahsoka,
and she's around her early forties,
so would actually be pretty easy to age.
Cameron Monahan up just a couple years,
a little bit older for him to fit in
with the characters in the timeline,
but they did sound pretty certain
that they would make a third game,
so they might make the third game before
he shows up in the live action series
based on the way they jump around
in the footage here in the montage
at the beginning with his voice over,
it sounds like he's been busy
helping people just across the galaxy
since the events of the last game.
It looks like he's fighting
some kind of dark Jedi.
Are people working with the inquisitors
or different armor?
This is a traditional inquisitor armor,
but they're wielding across hilt
lightsaber here.
They're either a Jedi who turned
or someone
who just stole the lightsaber off
another Jedi after they died.
I'm also inclined to think
it's just that High Republic Jedi
like the main villain of the game.
And that's why he has the cross,
a lightsaber that looks all raw
and he's just wearing a helmet.
We see Marin come back.
She was a nice sister.
That's why she has those tattoos
and force abilities and the green fire.
She's using her nicest
Air Force techniques
to ask him to look into her fire,
to see a vision.
And that's what they use.
The fire for a lot.
They did this kind of thing
during the Clone Wars
and Star Wars
Rebels, a lot with the nice sister
characters and Darth Maul character
because he is also from Dathomir.
So they featured him a lot on that planet.
I'm not sure which planet
this is supposed to be.
It looks kind of like Coruscant,
but I don't think it's core site
because remember, we're ten years
after Revenge of the Sith.
The Empire would have firmly taken over
in their seat of power
would have been on course.
And so you would want to stay away
from there as far as possible.
It might be Green's homeworld in the mid
rim because you see Merrin
talking about the fire warming him,
keeping him company as he's
hugging and reuniting with Griese.
The whole idea with the Galaxy
is the closer you get to the core worlds,
the more developed, the richer
the older the planets get.
Basically.
So the most powerful planets
tend to be in the middle rim.
In the galactic core Marin's metaphor
about her Knights sister, Fire says left
unchecked, it will consume everything
until there's only ash,
which is a dark side of the force
reference,
like the hate,
the fear within him or the fire,
which is also supposed to be a reference
to the villain of the story,
the other ancient Jedi
who's been consumed by his hate,
been stewing in that backed a tank
for all these hundreds of years,
just getting madder and madder
about what happened with the galaxy
going to crap like, Oh,
how dare you destroy the galaxy
while I was in the tank?
He sounds so pissed during this.
It'll be interesting to see
when they actually meet in Calabasas.
Gets all excited like,
Oh my God, I found another Jedi.
This is so wonderful.
And then he starts telling him
what actually happened
with the Fall of the Jedi Order 66, and
he starts to get more and more pissed off.
A lot of great stuff happening.
Jedi order reached this big zenith,
but then, you know,
couple of minor
things happened, a couple setbacks.
A whole bunch of us wound up dying.
Most of the rest of us are on the run.
Make sure you watch out for
someone named Mannequin Skywalker.
We see more footage of Marin
using her force
abilities, fighting stormtroopers,
also footage of her fighting with Cal cast
as this is a brand new character
named Acuna.
He's a mercenary character who winds up
helping Cal Cassius metaphorically
and literally, because you see them both
fighting a k-2so droid together.
Speaking of K-2so, I believe he's supposed
to appear during season two of Star Wars
and or this isn't meant to be the k-2so
from Rogue One, though.
This is just meant to be part
of that type of droid.
And this signal might
just be the one that leads them
to the surviving High Republic Jedi.
But the voiceover fighting for a place
beyond the control of the Empire,
I think is just meant
to be a metaphor for them surviving
the Empire like the place is the galaxy.
Just in general,
after the events of Return of the Jedi, as
in the title of the game,
The Jedi Survive the Empire.
We get a little more B.D.
one footage.
They actually just featured BD one
in a couple episodes
of The Mandalorian, Season
two in Season three.
I don't remember if he was featured
during season one.
I think he just appeared in season
two when Mando
sort of building his Naboo Starfighter.
I know there's always a lot of questions
about who knew what,
who knew where everybody was during
different parts of the timeline.
But the idea is that the main galaxy
of Star Wars is a vast, a vast place.
The Mandalorian, for example,
barely knew about Jedi characters at all
when he first took up the mission
to take Grogu back to his people, quote
unquote, to the other Jedi
looking for Luke Skywalker,
even though he didn't realize
it was Luke Skywalker he was looking for.
He referred to them as ancient sorcerers.
That's how little he knew about the Jedi.
There's this whole idea that he's
still trying to resuscitate
the Jedi order, going around,
finding other force sensitive people
and helping people along the way.
One of the people that the whole crime
leads him to is this person here.
But it sounds like it's
one of those situations
where he rescues this force
sensitive person
who's really bitter about what happened
with Order 66, the emperor, Darth Vader.
Turning to the dark side,
he says, I will not be imprisoned again.
And he sounds really dark.
So he says that they might come to blows
because of their differing ideas
about what they should actually do
about the empire moving forward.
Because you also see this new character
talking to the mercenaries.
The calculus was fighting
in the other part of the trailer
when they refer to the Jedi,
giving them problems, so to speak,
like they're going to continue
to fight each other throughout the game.
He holds up the device and says,
Not as long as we have this.
It seems like a tracking device that helps
him clock caucuses around the galaxy.
Cere Junda comes back.
It looks like she's been taking care
of a new Jedi library
or the remnants of the old one.
It meant to look
just like the old Jedi library.
We see him fighting a whomp,
not on an ice planet
inside an imperial base, fighting similar
types of dark trooper robots
that we saw on The Mandalorian series
much later in the timeline.
I'm assuming these dark trooper
robots are different
from the ones that Moff Gideon created
because I think his we're supposed
to build upon years of imperial
engineering and research.
They were way more hardcore
than the ones that Cal Carstens
was fighting in this scene.
Here we see him stopping
the Blaster shots in midair like Kylo Ren.
The other big change to
this isn't the big Kylo Ren Easter egg.
He has a cross hilt light saber
just like Kylo Ren did,
except his doesn't
look all janky like Kylo Ren's did.
The actual synopses for the story
just reads.
During Star Wars, Jedi survivor
Callixtus is pushed further
to the outer
rim of the galaxy by the Empire.
Darth Vader, the Emperor, the Inquisitors.
The game picks up five years
after Star Wars, Jedi Fallen Order.
Notice the new scars on his face.
Look, he's got a bunch of extra city
miles on him.
He crashes their spaceship
during the events of the game.
They say Cal Casas considers himself a
Jedi knight like he's a Padawan no longer.
They also say that during that five year
time jump, he's had many subsequent run
ins with the Imperials inquisitors
since the end of Jedi Fallen Order.
They've already done
the Inquisitors in live action.
And like I said, this game in particular
takes place at the exact same time
that the Obi-Wan Kenobi
episodes are taking place.
Yet the picture Darth Vader using
the inquisitors to go after Callixtus
in much to the grand inquisitors chagrin
all of his attention
shifts to this Obi-Wan Kenobi person.
It is the picture Darth Vader being like,
okay, we have history.
I need to focus on Obi-Wan Kenobi
right now.
I've been obsessed with him for the past
ten years since Revenge of the Sith.
He would definitely be
way more obsessed with Obi-Wan Kenobi
than he would be with Carl KASELL.
Like he'd be pissed off about what
happened at the end of Jedi Fallen order.
But he's been way more pissed off
about what happened with Obi-Wan Kenobi
in his scarring on Mustafar.
Then we have a couple of new antagonists,
like we have
this new Jedi character that he rescues
who seems like he falls to darkness.
And this is a creepy looking senator on
Coruscant who seems like he's after him,
even though that looks kind of
like the Grand Inquisitor.
He's not meant to be the Grand Inquisitor.
He's supposed to be
a brand new senator character
that they're introducing for the game.
But because this is taking place
during the events of Obi-Wan Kenobi,
we know a lot about what happens
later in the timeline because we don't see
another real Jedi Academy forming
until Luke Skywalker creates his.
During the events
of The Mandalorian series,
we also found out that the planet
that that Jedi Academy is on
is offices, which has a deep history
in Star Wars lore.
It goes all the way back in the legends
canon.
They explained that
that was the main planet
that the Jedi Order moved
to, that more modern Jedi order
when it formed.
After they left Titan,
which was the other planet
they visited in the Mandalorian series,
where Grogu,
who sent out the beacon in the forest
to basically anybody that could hear it.
He was just lucky that Luke Skywalker
was the first person
to respond to the Beacon,
because it wasn't just a beacon
to the Jedi, it was a beacon to anyone
who was for sensitive and could detect it.
They're also a lot of people
that we know about who survived,
who are just waiting to come back
in the live action projects,
who would have heard it, too.
Both bad and good people.
A lot of that stuff, they're saving
for the future live action series.
Like we'll get into a lot of force lore
during the Ahsoka series in particular.
Those episodes will be coming
right after the Mandalorian Season
three,
probably sometime around the summer.
Like late summer maybe,
but that'll take place
during the same part of the timeline,
or at least the main part of the series.
They'll probably be some flashbacks
during it because I believe Hayden
Christensen is also supposed
to show up during that,
but either have to be as a force ghost
or it would be flashbacks.
Probably one of the other coolest things
during the trailer,
though, is the dual wielding like dual
building becomes a big feature in the game
and it doesn't have to be
you holding a regular double
bladed lightsaber and breaking it apart.
It is like two completely different
lightsabers that you get to use.
But if there are any other Easter
eggs or questions you have about
what's going on during the events of this,
or how this crosses over with the other
big characters in the Star Wars universe
just right up below in the comments.
Big Reminder
My Mandalorian Season three Episode
four video will post on Wednesday
after they release it,
so be sure to enable alerts for my channel
so you don't miss that.
Everyone click here for that all data link
as soon as I post it
and click here for all
my other Mandalorian Episode Videos.
Thank you so much for watching.
Everyone stay safe.
And this is the way.